BUT LeBRON JAMES HAS SAT DOWN AT
THE PODIUM.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
>> HEY, LeBRON.
IF WE COULD JUST ZOOM OUT AND
PUT THIS YEAR AND KIND OF LAST
YEAR INTO CONTEXT AND WHAT THIS
JOURNEY WAS LIKE IN SORT OF HOW
TONIGHT WAS A CULMINATION OF HOW
THIS SEASON WENT IF YOU AGREE
WITH THAT.
>> I MEAN, PRETTY MUCH.
I MEAN, IT'S KIND OF HARD TO
START THINKING ABOUT WHEN WE GOT
STARTED.
THE SEASON STARTED SO FAST AFTER
LEAVING THE BUBBLE, OBVIOUSLY,
YOU KNOW.
AND I THINK I WAS TALKING TO WES
IN THE LOCKER ROOM JUST A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
I SAID THE ONE THING THAT
BOTHERS ME MORE THAN ANYTHING IS
WE NEVER GOT TO SEE OUR FULL
TEAM BECAUSE OF INJURY OR COVID
OR SOMETHING GOING ON WITH OUR
BALL CLUB THIS YEAR.
WE COULD NEVER FULLY GET INTO A
RHYTHM AND NEVER REALLY SEE THE
FULL POTENTIAL OF WHAT WE'RE
CAPABLE OF.
BUT ALL IN ALL, YOU KNOW, I GIVE
MY HATS OFF TO EVERYONE ON THIS
TEAM THAT SHOWED UP EVERY DAY AT
WORK, SHOWED UP EVERY DAY TO
COMPETE, SHOWED UP EVERY DAY TO
PUT IN THE TIME AND EFFORT AND
OBVIOUSLY FELL SHORT OF OUR
GOAL, BUT, YOU KNOW, TRY TO DO
EVERYTHING WE COULD TO BE AS
GREAT AS WE COULD BE UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND ALSO GIVE -- I ALSO WANT TO
GIVE A SHOUT-OUT TO PHOENIX,
TOO.
MONTE WILLIAMS AND THAT TEAM,
THEY WERE EXCELLENT THROUGHOUT
THE SERIES, ALL OF THEM.
SO MUCH RESPECT.
>> AND HOW DID YOU COME THROUGH
ALL OF THIS PHYSICALLY?
I GUESS FROM THE ANKLE INJURY ON
AND WHAT IN THE OFF SEASON,
HAVING AN ACTUAL FULL OFF SEASON
DO FOR YOU AT THIS STAGE OF YOUR
CAREER?
>> WELL, IT'S GOING TO WORK
WONDERS FOR ME, OBVIOUSLY.
OBVIOUSLY DURING THE SEASON, I
DON'T LIKE TO PUT MY MIND FRAME
INTO THAT.
IT MAKES ME WEAK, YOU KNOW.
BUT IN THE OFF SEASON, YOU KNOW,
I GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO REST.
I GOT LIKE THREE MONTHS TO
RECALIBRATE, GET MY ANKLE BACK
TO 100% WHERE IT WAS BEFORE THE
ATLANTA GAME AND THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FOR ME.
EVERYBODY ELSE FEELS EXTREMELY
WELL.
MY ANKLE WAS THE ONLY THING
THAT'S KIND OF BOTHERING ME.
OBVIOUSLY BOTHERING ME IN THE
LATER STAGE OF THE SEASON AND